[Music]
19:22 is directed by zack Hilditch and
stars Thomas Jane and his third Stephen
King adaptation after dreamcatcher and
the mist this is also the third Stephen
King adaptation film we've gotten
recently after it and Gerald's game this
one just like Gerald's game debuted on
Netflix and this is based off a Stephen
King short story about a family who
lives on a farm in 1922 a husband a son
and a mother and after years of
arguments and financial disputes the
husband begins to plan to kill his wife
and tries to get his son to help him
1922 was one of my favorite Stephen King
short stories it was very contained very
claustrophobic it knew exactly where to
hit you in regards to this murder plot
it was about guilt it was about the
trauma of a bad marriage the trauma of a
bad childhood being roped into a
financial scheme and how one bad
decision can basically ruin your life as
well as everyone else's as far as the
most recent Stephen King adaptations
this is probably the weakest of the
three and it will often be compared to
that at least now in the future probably
not so much as people see it and forget
that it came out in this gigantic influx
of Stephen King adaptations but it's
unfair I think to compare it to it and
Gerald's game even though it's not the
best of the three the original short
story is also probably the weakest of
the source material that these films are
adapting and this film captures it
beautifully it's very faithful Thomas
Jane gives one of the best performances
I've ever seen from him he plays a
rancher who isn't as simple-minded as
actors often portrayed these types of
characters he's very smart he's
conniving he knows exactly what he wants
and he knows the evil ways to get it but
he's not dumb he doesn't play this
character like he's stupid this is one
of the better performances I've seen
from an actor this year I thought he was
really magnificent I was honestly blown
away for the first act
it is so taut and very suspenseful it's
masterfully helmed and as we watch this
murder plot develop between the father
and son I found it really riveting once
the second and the third act hits the
film sometimes slows down in regards to
pacing because it's really about one man
and his son rotting away we get to see
the repercussions of a horrible act and
how this can weigh on someone's mind so
much that everything else in their life
becomes meaningless and the guilt that's
associated with doing something so
horrible consumes his life and almost
everyone around him but I would say the
weakest element of this movie is that
once the film hits that point the high
point of the short story the film
doesn't always exactly know what to do
after that beyond showing this guy
rotting away and this is cool because
this is exactly what happened in the
short story but as a film I think it was
stretched too long the runtime is about
an hour and 41 minutes and this easily
could have been an 80 to 90 minute film
there's a lot here that we don't need
the point has already been made and
sometimes the film keeps giving and
giving and the pacing suffers as a
result
that's my only real issue with this
movie it captures the source material
really beautifully it's extremely well
shot Thomas Jane is excellent in this
film and as we watch a father and son
deal with the colossal consequences of a
horrible decision the message really
hits home I'm gonna give 1922 a B the
patient could have been better some of
it could have been trimmed but it is
extremely well acted and very faithful
to the short story it's on Netflix now I
recommend checking it out guys thank you
so much for continuing to watch the
fifth annual Halloween special as always
if you liked this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]